Do you believe that only the Earth is flat,
then?
What about the other planets?
The thing about people who believe the Earth
is flat is that it's not actually a belief
that the Earth is flat.
It's actually just an assertion about doubting
everything that exists.
Everything we know; science, institutions.
I did a big, deep dive on this and learned
a lot about Flat Earthers.
And yeah, there are some people doing science
about it, whatever.
But most people are doing the Flat Earth thing
as just a big F-you to science that they can't
see and understand and measure themselves.
And so they just doubt it.
And it feels really good for them.
And so that's why these arguments don't really
go anywhere.